yeah welcome a new game play for for a
change against kamalia supposedly from
north north korea this is now gimme
popinski get a purple scheme hmm not
sure if this is a real person probably
it is not from North Korea they don't
have any chess players as far as I'm
aware maybe I'm terribly wrong but I
don't think they have I name okay so
we've got a French terra ceia don't
let's see what line is coming up with
here like has got many many moves not
sure why is thinking so long
so yeah this is some something like like
the mainline 96k they usually play
Knight f6 not that I'm really a way I
wife okay well night be 3s it's normal I
don't think it cannot play five year ok
so let's just take it
so young I think c33 neff three or so
something like this yeah this is why
they often play queena three to sort of
play against be five maybe you can do
that do this anyway sometimes this as
possible probably not here as you can
sometimes trap the Queen but then ok so
to be 30 i have my official def also I
not not now but I mean it's a it's a
it's an idea to disagree let's stay here
and if I if I have the knight on d4 and
the bishop won't be three it always
needs to think of on sacrifices on e6
and maybe this irritates him a bit with
this development yes just taking the
h2porn I still wonder what about like a
Lego Bishop g5 it's kenny and maybe i
can take n play Bishop b5 probably mmm
okay so okay let's spend too much time
last game I lost simply due to my the
touristy bad time management
yeah a lot of it is really due to the
commentary and sometimes really get
caught up in in ideas and try to really
figure out what is what's the best
movement and such this is sometimes not
the most effective approach and blitz
and what is this don't do I have some
tactic
rupee 6
I don't know rookies six yes 95 m yeah
yes 95 on rookie six okay yeah Bishop g5
is just to play work T 1 on Knight e5 I
go Queen age 56 I need to check this
afterwards takes Knight x looks quite
interesting to say the least but I think
he can play 95 on mochi six I can play
95 a thing and nobody is spending his
sweet time a small wait what Bishop c2
isn't this decimal okay come on who's
saying that i always need to place up
Thomas looking for booth look H floor
come on let's go
o gauge for I think it's a threat to him
really
yeah okay what else and now look before
I thought isn't there look chief for or
should I take on age 16 interesting look
at you for Butchie frolics fine I think
this should be a tower 796 and this
should I should win really
you should be five this should be five
and i was i wasn't really calculating it
i mean what i think it should that
should be working 96 yeah yeah Jeff
hmm
I can I can play I can take hear you
Green age five and Bishop h5 with a
chick and he i can I can take I can take
all this stuff wait can be to check
check
isn't this winning it would be a shame
if it wasn't maybe maybe it is not
winning it as possible got four pawns
Jeff
check
check
time warning
yeah maybe I should take the draw I'm
sure maybe this is too much check check
check check ten seconds well okay that
computer says it's a draw and of course
I'm winning with rupee am yeah it's easy
not even easy about 12 seconds yeah it's
not it's not difficult yeah the cash
Jack it's not difficult to hear this
track okay here just drew key aide he
needs to take it okay okay and I got the
queen but I was down to 10 seconds stp
simply too little time I wonder if I had
a win before I mean it's looking so
dangerous Queen age 6 checkmate Queen
age 6 leads to a mate okay
hmm yeah
I'm threatening queen afraid also whoo
Quinn f8 as a huge threat okay and if he
takes here I fruit h4 ah very nice this
I could this I could have found but I
thought thought really this distress
should be should be enough as well okay
okay no g5 is correct and now look you
wanna swing again so i gave a couple of
checks and i haven't played this so this
is winning yeah yeah yeah i played it
right i played it even correctly rookie
won and now this is a plus 6 yeah yeah I
felt it must be winning this King the
light Queen unit for porn so it's it's
like I'm just need to win an exchange or
something this night for for Lucas or
crew change of Queens and I'm winning
this easily with so many poems yeah this
is rook e8 winning now when I was down
to 16 seconds yeah but a fun game i hope
you hope you enjoyed it